Also meine Traum...
Meine Traumwohnung sollte
einen Balkon haben. - Jawohl.
Damit ich Pflanzen setzen kann.
Damit ich Töpfe hinstellen kann.
Die Bettwäsche
muss ich alle zwei Wochen waschen.
Daran bin ich jetzt gerade.
Dann
muss ich das Bett frisch beziehen
und am Schluss noch den Boden saugen
und ihn feucht aufnehmen.
Würden Sie mit dieser Liste
dann auch arbeiten,
wenn Sie alleine wohnen?
Würden Sie sie nehmen,
um zu kontrollieren,
ob Sie an alles gedacht haben?
- Ja, genau.
Eigentlich brauche ich die Liste
schon fast nicht mehr,
ich erledige die Aufgaben
schon recht selbstständig.
Ich habe es immer wieder gemacht
und habe deshalb
mittlerweile eine gewisse Routine
und weiss, was die Aufgaben sind
und wie sie erledigt werden.
Vorsicht, ich bin beladen!
Joël Hofstetter und Janine Zobrist
träumen von einem selbstbestimmten
Leben in einer eigenen Wohnung.
Wegen ihrer
kognitiven Beeinträchtigung
müssen sie sich ihren Traum
hart erarbeiten.
Dieser Film begleitet sie dabei.
Die Behindertenorganisation
Pro Infirmis
betreibt im Kanton Zürich
eine Wohnschule mit zwei Standorten.
Die Ausbildung dauert je nach
Lernfortschritt zwei bis drei Jahre.
Während der Grundausbildung
leben die Wohnschülerinnen
und -schüler gemeinsam in einer WG.
* Gemächliche Musik *
Was lernen Sie denn hier, damit es
dann mit dem Alleinwohnen klappt?
Zum einen ist das
der Umgang mit sich selber.
Und zum anderen lernen wir auch,
mit anderen Leuten umzugehen.
Ist das am Anfang
schwierig zu lernen?
Ich finde nicht.
Weitere Schwerpunkte der Ausbildung
sind die Haushaltsführung,
der Umgang mit Geld
und die Freizeitgestaltung.
Janine.
- Ja?
Weisst du, wo diese ...
... wo diese verstaut werden?
Die kommen
dort neben die anderen hin.
Hier?
- Ja.
Der nächste Punkt wäre,
darüber zu sprechen,
was überhaupt ein Konflikt ist.
Heute leitet der Sozialpädagoge
Sandro Weber den Unterricht.
... was wir für Erfahrungen
mit Konflikten gemacht haben.
Es gibt psychische
und physische Gewalt.
Hier in Altstetten leben zurzeit
vier Wohnschülerinnen und -schüler.
Die Stube ihrer WG ist gleichzeitig
das Unterrichtszimmer.
Danke. Das ist sehr ...
"Der Schlauere gibt nach,
der Esel bleibt stehen."
Heute mache ich Spaghetti mit Pesto.
Was, du machst heute
Spaghetti mit Pesto? - Ja.
Das will ich aber nicht.
Nein, heute gibt es Spaghetti ...
Ich weiss gar nicht.
Ich will ... Spaghetti Napoli.
Ich will, dass du mir das machst.
Ja, wir könnten ja
auch beides machen.
Nein, ich will Spaghetti Napoli.
Ich will Spaghetti Napoli.
Machst du mir jetzt Spaghetti Napoli
oder nicht?
Äh ... also, wenn du so mit mir
sprichst, dann sicher nicht.
* Klatschen *
Ich möchte,
dass du Spaghetti Napoli machst.
* Alle lachen. *
Was denkt ihr:
Was habe ich jetzt versucht?
Äh ... nachgeben.
Habe ich nachgegeben?
- Nein, sie.
Hat sie nachgegeben?
- Durchsetzen.
Genau, ich habe versucht,
mich durchzusetzen.
Das war ziemlich rabiat.
- Genau.
Und du hast recht: Für so jemanden
würde ich auch nichts kochen.
Aber was wäre jetzt gewesen,
wenn sie gesagt hätte:
"Okay, dann mache ich dir
Spaghetti Napoli."?
Dann hätte ich nachgegeben.
- Genau.
Und wenn du
einfach weggegangen wärst?
Dann wäre ich dir
aus dem Weg gegangen.
Die Wohnschülerinnen und -schüler
führen ihren Haushalt gemeinsam.
Morgen muss Janine Zobrist für
die ganze WG das Mittagessen kochen.
Die 25-Jährige bespricht mit
Sozialpädagogin Nuria van der Kooy
die Einkaufsliste.
Brauchst du noch Schinken?
Ja, hierfür auch.
Das sind auch wieder zwölf Scheiben.
- Ja.
Dazu schaust du am besten auch auf
der Packung, wie viele es drin hat.
Ich weiss, dass in einer Packung
zehn Scheiben drin sind.
Okay, dann musst du
wirklich noch eine mehr nehmen,
damit es dann genug hat.
Bevor sie die Wohnschule besuchte,
lebte Janine Zobrist in verschiedenen
sozialpädagogischen Einrichtungen.
Sie hat grossen Ehrgeiz, möglichst
bald selbstständig leben zu können.
Als ...
Als Nächstes ...
... brauchen wir ...
... Käsescheiben.
Wie Joël Hofstetter hat auch
Janine Zobrist eine Lernbehinderung.
Sie kann lesen, schreiben, rechnen.
Aber sie braucht dafür
etwas mehr Zeit.
Alltägliche Tätigkeiten
sind für sie oft Herausforderungen,
die sie
Schritt für Schritt lernen muss.
Mussten Sie lange üben,
bis es klappte, alleine einzukaufen?
Ja.
- War das schwierig zu lernen?
Ja, es ist eben
schon nicht ganz einfach.
Ich muss noch kurz kontrollieren,
ob ich alles habe.
Das macht 60.40 Fr.
Danke schön.
Heute steht
eigentlich nur Hörnli und Gehacktes.
Das ist das Mittagsmenü.
Dazu gibt es Salat.
Das bereiten alles Sie vor?
Für die ganze WG?
Ja, das muss alles ich vorbereiten.
Wenn möglich alleine,
ohne Hilfe des Teams.
Okay.
Ich beginne einmal
mit der Bouillon im Massbecher.
Das habe ich gestern
schon alles bereitgestellt.
Und jetzt sollte ich noch wissen,
wie viel ich brauche.
Äh ... wo haben wir's?
Sandro, kannst du mir kurz helfen?
- Ja.
Wie viel ist ein Deziliter?
- Da müssen wir kurz schauen.
Es ist hier
nicht so deutlich angezeigt,
aber du kannst es bis hier füllen.
Bevor Joël Hofstetter
in die Wohnschule eintrat,
lebte der 25-Jährige
bei seiner Mutter.
Nach acht Monaten Unterricht
braucht er bei
den alltäglichen Herausforderungen
immer weniger Unterstützung
von Sozialpädagoge Sandro Weber.
Ein Deziliter.
- Perfekt.
Du kannst auf diese schauen.
Es ist auf derselben Höhe
wie die blaue Linie.
Okay. Und wie viel brauche ich,
habe ich gesagt?
Hast du nicht das Gefühl, dass
die Pfanne schon sehr heiss ist?
Doch, sie wird sehr heiss. - Sollen
wir sie auf die Seite stellen? - Ja.
Loretta, Larissa, Janine, du, ich
und ... wollen Sie auch mitessen?
Ich filme, ich esse nicht mit.
Ein Gang für fünf Leute.
- Gut.
Genau. - Bis ich
Zwiebeln und so reintue ...
* Klingelton *
- Ja, ich weiss.
Das wäre der Wecker gewesen,
der mich daran erinnert,
dass ich
die Hörnli jetzt rausnehmen kann.
Dass die Nudeln gut sind.
Ja, aber ich habe
vorher gerade probiert
und ich schätze einmal grob,
dass sie um zehn nach fertig sind.
Da bin ich jetzt
ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher,
weil ich hier
nur Teigwaren drin hatte.
Ich muss Sandro fragen,
ob ich das nochmals putzen muss.
Ob Sie die Tasse auswaschen müssen.
- Ja, es waren nur Teigwaren drin.
Die würde ich nehmen, Joël.
- Okay.
Unbedingt,
ich finde sie schon fast zu weich.
Ja?
- Nimm sie, die sind schon noch gut.
Ah ja.
Ich nehme das kurz raus, damit du
sie abgiessen kannst. - Danke.
Geht's?
- Ich probiere es einmal.
Einen guten Appetit miteinander.
Danke fürs Kochen.
Bitte.
- Ja, danke fürs Kochen.
Das Schulgeld von 3'600 Fr. im Monat
wird durch die IV
und mit Ergänzungsleistungen bezahlt.
Für die Sozialwerke
geht die Rechnung auf.
Denn sie sparen langfristig Geld,
wenn sie es Menschen mit
einer Beeinträchtigung ermöglichen,
selbstständig zu leben.
Die Wohnschülerinnen und -schüler
arbeiten halbtags auswärts.
Janine Zobrist hat einen Job
bei der St. Jakob-Bäckerei in Zürich.
Hier arbeiten Menschen
mit einer Beeinträchtigung
Seite an Seite mit gelernten Bäckern.
Ja?
- Schau, so, ganz wenig.
Ganz wenig?
- Ganz wenig, überall.
Von hier bis da drüben.
Diesen habe ich schon gemacht. Du
kannst beim nächsten weitermachen.
So ist gut. Mach oben weiter!
War es schwierig, alles zu lernen,
was Sie hier können müssen?
Oder war das einfach für Sie?
Also, am Anfang war es
schon schwierig für mich.
Äh!
Ist da alles fertig?
- Ja.
Dann kannst du nach Hause gehen.
- Dann kann ich nach Hause gehen.
Dann kommst du am Montag wieder?
Ja, am Montag nächste Woche
arbeite ich noch,
dann habe ich zwei Wochen Ferien.
- Bei Mami?
Ja.
- Janine, ciao, bis Montag.
Tschüss, bis Montag.
Hast du schon Vorstellungen, was ...
- Zoo Zürich.
Ehrlich?
- Ja.
Okay, willst du zu den Pinguinen?
Die Wohnschule
macht einen Ausflug nach Winterthur.
Du hast den Schlüssel, oder?
- Ja.
Ah ja,
da ist es schon angeschrieben.
Pro Infirmis Zürich, Wohnschule.
Hier hat die Pro Infirmis
eine Einzimmerwohnung gemietet.
Können Sie uns erklären,
was das für eine Wohnung ist?
Das ist eine Wohnung, in der man
zwei Wochen probewohnen kann.
Dann wohnt man alleine hier.
Zum Üben, wie es ist,
alleine zu wohnen? - Ja.
Haben Sie das auch vor?
- Ja.
Wann denn?
- Im Januar.
Freuen Sie sich schon darauf?
- Ja, sehr.
Worauf freuen Sie sich am meisten?
Dass ich selber meine Kochkünste
ausprobieren kann.
Sehr gut.
Was bedeutet das Zeichen hier oben?
- Lautsprecher.
Genau.
Würdest du jedem öffnen, der klin-
gelt? Auch wenn du ihn nicht kennst?
Nein, ich würde zuerst hören,
wer es ist
und dann auch fragen, wer da ist.
Denn ich mache wildfremden Personen
nicht einfach die Tür auf.
Du hast recht.
- Ja.
Was könnte das da oben noch sein,
Janine?  - Der Alarm.
Nein, hier ist der Strom.
Wenn eine Sicherung
rausfliegen würde, wüsstest du,
wie du sie wieder reinmachen kannst?
- Hä?
Weisst du, was du machen könntest,
wenn es dunkel wäre?
Lies einmal, was hier steht!
Kochherd, Bad, Gang, Wohnen, Küche.
Mach ihn mal runter!
- Das?
Drück mal hier runter!
Oh!
- Jetzt hat's keinen Strom mehr.
Jetzt hat es wieder.
Manchmal fliegt der raus, dann muss
man ihn wieder nach oben drücken.
Könnten Sie denn schon alles, um eine
Woche alleine hier wohnen zu können?
Ja, ich überlege noch
wegen der Rezepte ...
Was die einfachsten Rezepte
für mich zum Kochen wären.
Ist das Kochen das Schwierigste,
wenn man alleine wohnt?
Ja, schon.
Hm. Gibt es noch andere Sachen,
die schwierig sein könnten,
wenn niemand von der Wohnschule
hier ist?
Äh ...
Putzen oder so?
Also beim Putzen habe ich keine ...
- Keine Probleme, oder? - Nein.
Hier testen die Wohnschülerinnen und
-schüler nicht nur ihre Fähigkeiten,
sie probieren auch aus, ob ihnen
das Alleinleben überhaupt gefällt.
Im Oktober gehst du weg.
Nein, ich gehe erst im Januar,
Lucky, weisst du.
Erst im Januar? - Ja.
- Erst im Januar.
Joël Hofstetter hat das Probewohnen
bereits hinter sich.
Mit Sozialpädagoge Sandro Weber
zieht er Bilanz.
Hier siehst du Kästchen.
Ich glaube, es ist selbsterklärend.
Du kannst ja super lesen. - Ja.
"Wie fühlte ich mich
in dieser Zeit?"
Hm.
Wie hast du dich gefühlt?
Ich habe mich eigentlich
sehr gut gefühlt.
Okay.
Es war auch eine Gewöhnungssache,
von Anfang an alleine zu sein.
Man hatte
niemanden zum Reden und so.
Das war aber
nur in den ersten zwei Tagen so.
Und dann hatte ich mich
daran gewöhnt, dass niemand da ist.
Was würdest du sagen?
Ich würde mir eine Zehn geben.
- Du hast dich sehr gut gefühlt?
Ja.
- Gut.
Ist es viel anstrengender
als hier in der Grundausbildung?
Nein. Zum Glück ist es ja
eine kleine Wohnung.
Und ...
Nein, eigentlich
war es nicht so anstrengend.
Bist du mit allem durchgekommen,
was du dir vorgenommen hattest?
Ja.
Was war das Beste an dieser ...
- Alleine zu sein.
Alleine zu sein? Dann kannst du es
ja hinschreiben: "Alleine zu sein."
Ich möchte aber noch wissen, warum.
Was ist das Gute am Alleinsein?
Es ist niemand da, der dich stresst.
Und ...
Man kann essen, wann man will.
Dann war es für dich kein Problem,
alleine zu sein.
Im Gegenteil: Du hast es geschätzt,
dass dir für einmal
niemand über die Schulter schaute.
Du hast die Planung selber gemacht,
bist selber einkaufen gegangen.
Das Geld ist aufgegangen.
Das ist wirklich toll.
Für uns stellt sich die Frage,
ob du dich schon bereit fühlst,
langsam mit der Wohnungssuche
zu beginnen? - Ja.
Joël, gut gemacht!
- Danke.
Und uns freut es natürlich,
dass es dir so gut gefallen hat
und dass dir die Zeit gezeigt hat,
dass es das ist, was du möchtest:
selbstständig leben.
D.h., du hast
eigentlich schon ein grosses Ziel,
das über der Wohnschule steht,
herausgefunden.
Und das ist: Wie will ich leben?
Nächsten Sonntag
im zweiten Teil dieser Geschichte:
Joël Hofstetter
sucht seine erste eigene Wohnung.
Janine Zobrist probt das Alleinwohnen
und empfängt erstmals Gäste.